[Musique]
bien grand mot d'ordre c'est bien ça
comme un adulte un grand bravo ont crié
c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue grand matin la chaloupe saint
leu pour 23 km et un territoire
exceptionnel à découvrir votre 300
coureurs au départ ça va être génial
entre la route départementale 3 et le
bord de mer
ça va être top
[Musique]
c'est bien ça donne des émotions
dimanche en cours
[Musique]
où l'on incognito la nouvelle traverser
la route hubert delisle route
départementale 3 voilà on est là sur
seront voilà le balcon la réunion et si
elle est si belle c'est qu'il ya une
raison
c'est ce qu'on vous explique tout de
suite mais nous on continue à mr voilà
ça tourne a quand même c'est parti
verra-t-on sont devant nous il avec
leurs hôtes au broyeur là bas donc nous
fait le côté droit et on te laisse la
partie aménagée sur la droite n'a eu une
autorisation de l'entretien des abords
qui a été conventionnée avec le
département et comme tu vas passionné
aussi de sport et que la dh organise de
travail dans l'année
bah métro que les une bonne
collaboration entre nous deux en fait
nous on aménage une entretien et on
embellit la route via notre pépinière
qu'on a à la dh on a des fleurs on a des
arbres on a un peu de tout et on
construit cet aménagement avec la
population bien entendu au par des
échanges de bons procédés des échéances
de champagne à ses fameux trail de allah
je dis pas cela
en voyant le travail que les faits
souvent on a des retombées positives il
ya nos bâtiments prochaine reprise
on attaque l'os entier c'est très lent
métropole mais bon y'a pas le dénivelé
quoi dure jamais fait une descente au
silo
ouais après je verrai mes fers il monte
aussi longue j'ai du plaisir
super à l'e3 c'est de finir les trois
cas il est des nôtres
il a fait son travail comme les autres
[Musique]
facile en soit en cas de figure précis
mais là il faut monter sur madame les
yeux des passants chine nouvelle je me
dépêche alors oui des personnes parce
que madame la finance et du barreau
allez madame boncourt à travailler parce
que c'est lui qui fume que l'on m'a dit
c'est que la technique très technique
c'est au coup son menton poussant monte
c'est tout ouais et on va y arriver mais
c'est sympa il fait beau problème cette
façon vous avez vu est différente
végétation partir de redescendre belle
affaire linverse tout ça c'est raconte
une histoire l'histoire de ce territoire
s'est tout de suite dentaire de travail
allez venez
[Musique]
dans mon temps les gens en fait surtout
les gamins ils allaient plutôt chercher
ces arbres là quand il se mettait en
route sur les sentiers on a un fois ici
si nous avons eu lieu donc en fait les
gens disaient aller retour vang et c'est
pour ça que si l'expression pour dire
faire l'école buissonnière
en fait quand vous faites la course vous
la faites en un temps très réduit et
vous parcourez ski pendant des années
s'est transformé dans le paysage donc
vous avez aussi un raccourci qui vous
est offert là vous avez en quelques
mètres l'opportunité de faire de
parcourir 800 mètres d'altitude de voir
comment les plantes se sont étagés en
fonction des conditions du climat le
mieux ce serait de revenir en famille
comme ça vous pouvez prendre le temps
vous pouvez re découvrir les plantes
vous pourrez mieux comprendre prendre du
bon temps on s'y sent elle dans des
connaissances trop scientifique
ou bien comme un cabri ah oui moi j'ai
pas pris franck à cabris sermon trade on
a retrouvé les acacias
c'est au top plus de deux heures de
course les premiers sont déjà arrivés
mais en même temps pourquoi faire on
n'est pas bien là
[Musique]
le mur je n'abuse on encore
fin de ce travail de la chaloupe
rien de mieux qu'un sentier pour
découvrir aller à la rencontre d'un
territoire d'une association début d
autres n'en trouve dans les sentiers